foreign
[Music]
Tunisian actions towards migrants preach
international law and we have seen now
forces expulsions which violate the
African Charter on human and people's
rights as well as the U.N convention and
other International treaties especially
when they are linked to racial ethnic or
national groups
everyone
foreign
ly authoritarian grip but it's also
bolstering the security appearances in
the name of stopping migration eu's role
is basically a containment policy that
is aggravating the situation in Tunisia
[Music]
thank you
the Libyan side will not take them they
say they already have enough migrants on
their own territory so in many ways the
migrants and Asylum Seekers are left to
themselves in this no man's land
[Applause]